happy Sunday reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we are going to watch
something that I miss because we haven't
seen one of these and so long and a
minute when the notifications in the
Commons came in today I was like miles
Aldo Joan's weird trailers is back baby
he's got it of course for Captain Marvel
that's why I'm wearing my Batman shirt
to represent female equality in the
industry and also represent Marvel this
thing guys before we hop into this I
want to say thank you to everyone who's
been following us in the Stardust app
over there we do 30-second reactions for
films TV shows trailers often turning
them into micro sketches been posting
pretty much daily sometimes twice a day
over there telling you guys I'm loving
the interaction we're having it's so
much fun please join us today it's free
to download free to use and this
shout-out is free we just really like it
let's get into this
[Music]
hahaha can I help you find something
Drac oh I get it
video stores are so old they have ghosts
in them okay thanks I get it but you're
wrong I know we're winning game so - yes
[Music]
the heavy murders of cyborgs invasion
how did you do that how did you go
invisible
[Music]
hate to shatter your ego but this ain't
the first time I've had a gun pointed
[Music]
god
got a small there's only one captain
ma'am
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I have no idea what's out there
ah
[Music]
[Music]
you know the box let's get out
[Music]
[Music]
zones killing the game mitad it 12
minutes minutes 12 second after we got
here yeah okay
it's guilin Raptor it's cool
congratulations Jost Mason sorry people
with the name Mason and Manson soon a
cussin final core don't worry I get a
try I'll just go to the timestamps in
the comments and find it there that way
I just want to hear this song in an
actual club setting oh that's right
venom one that's last one last time we
saw one right and brilliantly sliced in
there loves loves those patrons
still a danny trejo Wonder Woman
Aldo Jones version of this every time I
Aldo Jones makes a weird trailer what I
imagine is him editing makes me wonder
like where your folder is of like things
that we always have to yeah like might
go to folder because we've started out
one of those four little things but I
imagine the Aldo Jones has one for a lot
of oh yeah I really like how he's been
taking control of these trailers lately
because he seems to be defining his own
pacing for it yeah in the beginning it
was just a lot of inserts and just
letting the trailer do its thing but I
noticed he's become so good at expanding
out the music expanding out the scenes
and really making his own kind of pacing
with it well it especially showed in the
fact of how he got stano's to appear in
here and feel like a scene that was a
watching take place and like none of
that in Captain Marvel trailer at all so
the fact that he was able to include
that and make it not seem like a jar II
like pacing shift I know it seems kind
of strange to point that out but I think
that he does a great job at the pacing
now of these things there's something
kind of weirdly fluid about the way it
all goes especially in the last like 30
to 40 seconds of this not the outro fun
actual trailer it was just escalating
lis getting more and more and more weird
and strange so I really think he's
mastering pacing so much more now yeah
when the fan of this thing actually
kinda I had to remind myself partway
through that this wasn't footage from
the original trailer and stuff in it it
becomes this beautiful like Homer
disappearing back into the bush moment
yeah and then I was like - the way he's
manipulating like freeze frames and
stuff more now you know I mean you have
the very obvious one with the bouncing
ricochet at the beginning but also you
have like Sam Jackson knocking and
knocking and knocking behind her and
things like that and the continuous
jokes that he does it's like you're
getting to a plug where we can
deconstruct her humor yeah of like Sam
Jackson gets shot it's funny because you
know taking the pole fiction line with
another very next frame exactly there's
continuity which I appreciate because
yeah I feel like in the earlier video
there was just a lot of randomness and
now the randomness is even kind of tying
together inside the trailer yeah and
also like the way he's making fun of
certain things in a way that you
wouldn't expect because a big part of
the trailer of the original one was how
Captain Marvel yeah and then in this
trailer please baby
how much farther in the other direction
can we get it yeah that's not like I
wonder where he sourced that shot from
because like it's actually profession
shot you know with that slow-mo like
boxing video style splatter yeah I've
seen someone who's editing style in the
way how sometimes when we're editing our
discussions we'll get a thought that
reminds us of something and then we'll
throw an answer of it it's like having
the grown-ups footage is such a random
thing to do but I can imagine editing
and then going oh yeah finding that
footage from that movie it reminds me of
that it's good a reaction shot dude this
is this is some great stuff from Aldo
man huh no she haven't been doing these
as often which has me concerned
yeah man are you okay you're right
you're losing something just losing the
spark man are you tired
Batman's newspaper he's sick of YouTube
you're going to twitch
oh man live streaming on Twitch and
people chime in what you doing buddy hey
before we wrap this video up though I
wanted to give a page from the day
shout-out to a lady named a Delia
Chamberlain Adelia talked to a weekly
over at her patreon she is a very
talented woman a very opinionated woman
and a very kind-hearted lady as well she
has this interesting condition and I'm
gonna just put it out there it's called
hypergraphia I think that's how you say
it hypergraphia and basically it's like
when she gets this urge to write she
starts G just uncontrollably starts
writing non-stop and I gotta tell you in
a way it's a curse but a gift because I
really wish sometimes I had that
condition it's a very productive curse
there's no how it could become like a
very obsessive thing that could probably
interfere with getting some other tests
done but I think he started embracing
that it can make some good things happen
and I also wanted to thank you for
giving me the tip about Black Friday to
get some blu-rays
on that day cuz I never thought of doing
Black Friday for that I've always
thought that's when you get like some
crazy some raisin you're like ps4 or
something crazy electronic device
no the discounts run deep and lastly you
love Captain Marvel you have a lot of
faith in this film you're excited for it
so I wanted to make sure to shout you
out on this video we love you and Delia
and I hope you're having a good weekend
and hopefully you'd do something a
little bit fun for Halloween alright
guys well you can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell and hey make sure to check us out
on the Stardust at 30-second reactions
for films TV shows trailers free to
download free to use everything's free
like Costco samples